first thing is i want to be able to
evaluate this nice and
quickly and be able to um refer to what
i'm doing
in a succinct way so i'm going to start
by letting this into the f
right so if you're talking about f 1 f
f2
and so on um you've got to say what f is
right so
expenses
great okay now we already were told in
the question
that there's room between one and two so
all you have to do for part a
is test out f1 which gives you what is
it
five minus five i'm sorry okay
just evaluate that and f two which i
think should give you six
yes yep okay and now you sort of just
have to do a little bit of a
flourish to explain what you're doing
okay so you've got your change of
science that's all you need to establish
right
should say since f is continuous
okay there must be a route between one
and two
or solutions
okay now to actually work out what it is
to some kind of accuracy right
i'll let you work out when when do you
think i should stop okay
how many times do you think i need to do
this before you can say yep one decimal
place
i can be confident okay so between one
and two
i'm going to bisect right hence
bisection method so let's test out 1.5
okay what is it equal to
yeah good okay
so since that's negative which way am i
going to have to go
right which where am i limited to now is
it between 1 and 1.5
or 1.5 and 2.
yeah so you always want to match up the
ones with opposite sign okay
so i'd say therefore the root or the
solution is between
x equals 1.5 and x equals two
okay so this is a pretty long form way
of writing it but it's pretty dark so
anyway now i'm going to bisect this
again
right so 1.75
and you get some other number let's see
it starts getting a little
decimal places start to get a bit crazy
so
i think that's what is that what you get
can you test that 1.75 yep
okay so therefore now i can say the
roots between where and where
1.75 is positive right and the one i had
before
that's negative right so i can match up
between those two
okay do i need to go another step
i i kind of think that steps enough um
let's just illustrate it for sure
because
when you look at by the way it's not
just knowing that they're negative and
positive okay
because when i look at these two values
i can also know
which is it closer to right see how this
is quite a bit above
right so what does that correspond to
the kind of graph right you've got minus
.875 so here and two right
sorry not quite that far right so you've
got one value here one value here
so probably unless it's like some kind
of weirdo function right
i can reasonably guess that it's going
to be closer to this side
than the other side right so in other
words i'm guessing it's more like 1.6
than 1.7
okay but just for the sake of it let's
do it one more time okay
so what's halfway between there and
there
one point what is halfway six seven five
two five
okay so you can see the kind of accuracy
you get is reflected in
how small these values are so the closer
i get to zero the closer i am
right so this is positive so i'm between
these two now
right so the root must be between
1.5 and uh
1.625
okay so this point they're pretty even
if i had to
bisect it and say right in the middle
that's closer i want one times replace
right
1.6 then 1.5 okay so i would say
x equals 1.5 sorry 6
is an approximate solution
okay and for those people who did go
further you can see at least like one
point five eight blah blah blah blah
okay so it does kind of work right uh
one of the great things about this is
that
this method that we're going through
right it's very very simple right a
computer can do it really well
and so if you ever get like you know
wolfram alpha and that kind of thing
you're like hey
solve this right in general because what
they're giving you is actually a
you know it's usually an approximation
especially if we don't function like
this okay
they're just going through this method
right because computers are really good
at this
okay they're not going they don't know
some special information like oh they've
got the kiwi formula
they don't do that they just go through
this and eventually they get to another
level accuracy that they're happy to
just give to you
okay